but journalists and best-selling artha
that's Michael Lewis says sports
officials are not the only ones feeling
the heat these days in his new podcast
it's called against the rules Lewis says
the authority of other referees in
American life like financial regulators
judges and public editors at newspapers
are under attack he argues when you have
a weak referee you got a really big
problem Michael Lewis good to see you
and let me say bravo and Congrats
yeah podcast was so good and so
interesting and so well done
and I know this is only Episode one so
let's see how you do well you know
always at the mercy of your material
right and the material here is
unbelievable this is what human referee
is on the run everywhere you see
everything less yeah unless he's bought
by somebody in which case the person who
bought them keeps them in place we in
the podcast I learned that refereeing is
100 percent negative business as you
point out they get a lot of refuse hook
refuse soaked refuse sucks and they have
that barrage every day and the the
reality is though that it's gotten
better yet the coaches and the fans
think it's gotten worse and the NBA is
spending a lot of money to get this
right you know that the basketball
professional basketball is a nice little
microcosm to start because you can see
in the last five years the new
Commissioner Adam Silver has engaged in
this pretty intense sort of effort to
reform referee to make it better
they built a fifteen million dollar
Center across the river here the replay
Center with how many screens one hundred
and ten screens and it's nothing but if
all those screens are connected by
direct fiber-optic cable to the [ __ ] to
the NBA arenas to give you them
different angles on the court and you
see nothing but the angles on the court
the whole point is just to give the
referees another tool to get it right
yeah but the refs are still mad but
their reps are trained in ways they
weren't trained before they have to
study their mistakes as they've never
had to study their mistakes before there
they are they're made aware of like the
various biases that their minds are
prone to there's no question that
they've got and you can measure they're
the actors that calls have gotten better
and yet people are angrier and angrier
and angrier isn't that part of the
fixing refereeing means making better
reps but don't we also have to be better
and not assume that they're gonna be
right a hundred percent of time every
time because that's the question so
you've got you got this conundrum he's
got you've got Ref
he's getting better at the same time
everybody dislikes them more what's
going on and I think you know they're
operating this is the problem they're
operating in a different environment
every mistake is now scrutinized and
there's a mechanism for generating
outrage about the mistakes the social
social media that all the forces that
are there to attack them are amplified
and there's nothing the forces to defend
themselves are not and that's kind of
the larger story right what you say is
what's happening to them tells us a lot
about what's happening to us yes the
arbiters of a game the arbiters of life
the judicial system all of it if you
look at what's happening in American
life and the with the American political
life yeah the campaign's in the last
presidential election they gained
traction it surprised people
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump they're
the source of their energy was anger
about unfairness mm-hmm everything's
rigged and that this is happening at the
same time that you have the people whose
job it is to ensure that things aren't
rigged or under new kinds of attack it's
really it's it's a very interesting
situation and the point of the podcast
is surround unspool it's sort of figure
out what are these forces at work that
that are undermining the RAF and the
basketball you can see one of the forces
that when you have these refs become
much more objective and more accurate
who gets angry the stars get angry yeah
because they're used to getting the
calls yeah so you're eliminating some
privilege so so what rest a genuinely
neutral ref is offensive to someone
who's in a position of privilege you
also saw racial bias and Ruffing that I
thought was interesting too well you
there was this this time I mean this is
like an example of how scrutinize those
referees are so there's a professor
named Justin Wolfers at the University
of Michigan he did this paper Australian
yes yes you're but he's showing that
there was a racial bias and the referee
we did this seven or eight years ago and
to me the interesting thing about the
paper was what happened after that that
he went back and studied it after and
Shane limited it I mean it was a story
about how they've gotten better and yet
nobody
you never hear anybody praised the rest
yeah all your both sides here thinks the
ref screwed
how could that be you would think for
everybody who's angry there'd be someone
who's happy but there's not and and
these pressure these these pressures on
the people whose job it is to ensure
fairness are an attack on fairness oh
it's so fast it's very interesting and
there's an experience I walk or Lewis
your your teenage son which results and
others thank you plug Walker all right
against the rules is available wherever
you get your podcast you are watching
CBS this morning guess what we're gonna
be right back